herr [ __ ] sie haben sich auf facebook
bereits sehr kritisch geäußert zu dieser
nacht am samstag in frankfurt was genau
macht sie so wütend
mich macht wütend dass es tatsächlich
wieder das klientel ist wie in stuttgart
das verschweigt man es ist eigentlich
egal welche tätergruppen so etwas machen
aber es ist auch in frankfurt wieder
bezeichnet gewesen dass das leute sind
die einfach sich nicht in unsere
gesellschaft integrieren wollen
was genau glauben sie ist der grund dass
sie dann so aggressiv der polizei
gegenüber werden
es wird die man als hauptgrund die
korona pandemie genannte dass klubs zu
sind und man dann in der öffentlichkeit
feiern muss das mag wohl auch ein
bestandteil dafür sein dass viele
menschen auf der straße sind aber die
die das auch in frankfurt zu beantworten
haben die randale gemacht haben
die gegen polizeibeamte vorgegangen sind
sind überwiegend leute junge leute mit
migrationshintergrund die in einer
parallelwelt leben die in facebook oder
instagram hier sich profilieren wollen
wenn sie videos hochladen und generell
ein problem haben mit staatlichen
institutionen
wir sehen die bilder aus frankfurt sind
wirklich erschreckende dann nachdem wir
gehört dass weinflaschen hagel der auf
die polizei nieder ging da was geht also
in den frau wenn sie jetzt hören dass
die 39 festgenommen dann bereits wieder
auf freiem fuß sind
jetzt kann man natürlich sagen das ist
ein schlag ins gesicht für die
eingesetzten kolleginnen und kollegen in
frankfurt
die teilweise auch verletzt wurden aber
das ist auch unser rechtsstaat das muss
man auch akzeptieren wenn es hier keine
gründe gibt die eine haft begründen also
keine haftgründe erkennbar sind dann
sieht dass unser rechtsstaat vor
das ist dann zugunsten der täter geht
und die dann natürlich dann auch wieder
freigelassen werden
das heißt aber nicht dass weiterhin
ermittlungen gegen sie laufen jetzt
haben sie gerade schon ihre verletzten
kollegen angesprochen wissen sie wie es
den verletzten polizisten von
samstagnacht geht natürlich kann mich da
auch nur auf die gewerkschaftlichen
die tanners berufen von den frankfurter
gewerkschaftskollegen und kollegen die
uns darüber informiert haben
ich meine die die körperlichen
verletzungen
die werden irgendwann mal heilen aber es
geht ja auch um die post traumatischen
verletzungen die da unsere einsatzkräfte
haben und das ist natürlich eine sache
die wird die alte auch noch eine zeit
lang beschäftigen vor frankfurt hatten
wir bereits seinen acht gesehen in
stuttgart ist die polizei überhaupt in
deutschland ausreichend für solche
situationen vorbereitet
ja die polizei ist natürlich ausreichend
für solche situationen vorbereitet
aber sie haben sich ja auch in den
beiträgen gesehen
teilweise kommt die polizei vor ort um
eine schlägerei schlichten einem
verletzten zu helfen und dann sind auf
einmal uhr plötzlich hunderte die sich
gegen die polizeistellen auch teilweise
in der unkenntnis warum die polizei da
gewesen ist das ist eine entwicklung wo
man sagen muss das macht mich sehr
traurig und auch sehr nachdenklich wenn
man jetzt diese bilder sieht und heute
gab es die sicherheitskonferenz zu
schalten gleich auch in die
pressekonferenz was dort dann
entschieden worden es ihrer meinung nach
was muss sich ändern was muss gemacht
werden damit es solche nächte nicht noch
in anderen großstädten in deutschland
gibt das problem wird wieder sein wie in
stuttgart die aufregung am anfang wird
groß sein
man wird medienwirksam sich beschädigte
polizeifahrzeuge
ich sage jetzt mal anschauen und dann
geht man nach ein paar tagen wieder zur
tagesordnung über was man machen muss
ist tatsächlich hier konsequente
handlungs maßnahmen wir hatten das
gleiche ihr auch mal in mannheim denen
verursachen oder den tätern hat man da
ordentlichen strafe aufgebrummt und auch
ein betretungsverbot für die innenstadt
oder was auch in stuttgart jetzt
diskutiert wird ein generelles
alkoholverbot auf öffentlichen plätzen
das sind eigentlich die mittel die man
hier anwenden könnte also denken sie
wenn es ein alkoholverbot gibt oder
bestimmte plätze nachts dann
geschlossen der mit dieses verbotenes
diese zu betreten man dagegen ankommen
könnte dass jugendliche sich zum feiern
treffen oder verschiebt man das problem
damit eigentlich nur ja man könnte
natürlich sagen das problem verschiebt
man aber wenn man jetzt auch hier einen
mann hat das wunderbar funktioniert wir
hatten so was ähnliches aus einer
kontrolle situation hat sich etwas
entwickelt und die umherstehenden meist
jugendlichen sind dann gegen die polizei
vorgegangen
man hat ja mit der stadt zusammen
erarbeitet man hat die videos
ausgewertet
es sind betretungsverbote ausgesprochen
worden und wir haben im moment ihren
mann in ruhe
erneut sollen die klubs ja
wahrscheinlich noch das ganze jahr
geschlossen bleiben es ist einer der
gründe immer wieder aufgezeigt wird dass
die jugendlichen eben nicht mehr
weggehen können glauben sie also dass
bis zum ende dieser corona maßnahmen wie
immer wieder mit solchen randalen
rechnen müssen
ja zumindest mal wird sich alles nach
draußen verlagern und es ist tatsächlich
so dass wenn die klubs weiterhin
geschlossen haben ist natürlich eine
größere größere menschenmenge auf
öffentlichen plätzen unterwegs und ich
denke dass noch die arbeit der polizei
nicht leichter sondern eher schwerer
wenn man gegen solche großen
personengruppen vorgehen muss wenn es
polizeiliches handeln erfordert ich
hatte gerade statt einfalt und die
polizei darauf vorbereitet ist aber wenn
es jetzt doch noch mal ganz konkret
gegen jugendliche geht gegen partywütige
man damit rechnen muss dass in den
nächsten monaten so weitergeht muss die
polizei jetzt noch einmal speziell auf
solche einsätze vorbereitet werden
zumindest mal ist natürlich ein immenser
aufwand an an polizeipersonal was man
zur verfügung stellen muss man macht das
ja sei jedes wochenende hier in
stuttgart dass man in hundertschaft
stärker präsenz zeigt und natürlich
wirkt das auch präventiv das ventil
polizei da ist das vielleicht der eine
oder andere sich überlegt ob er da jetzt
randale in der innenstadt macht und ich
denke die polizei ist
vorbereitet aber dieses lied an diesen
personalaufwand den kann man also nicht
monate lang aufrechterhalten
letzte frage bevor wir dann in die
pressekonferenz schauen
denken sie es wird für die 39 zunächst
festgenommenen harte strafen geben oder
dass sie doch vielleicht mit sanften
bewährungsstrafen davonkommen
ich denke schon wenn man also
beweismittel hat und die videos die ja
teilweise auch ins netz gestellt werden
jetzt ist ja auch ein phänomen die haben
ja überhaupt kein recht
unrechtsbewusstsein dass sie sich ja
selbst auch filmen und ich denke dass
die auswertung der videoaufnahmen da den
einen oder anderen gegner noch zur
strecke bringt und er seine strafe dann
bekommen